porque existe esta tendencia a reprimir
a la prensa avanza el tiempo avanzan
derechos en otros ámbitos pero la
represión a los medios continúa pese a
los llamados
periódicos de organizaciones
internacionales
pues
muchos gobernantes que éste creen que
tener una prensa que les critica es algo
que les debe preocupar
un buen ejemplo aquí es el presidente de
lópez obrador quien se dedica de manera
regular a hostigar e intimidar a los
medios en sus conferencias matutinas las
mañaneras como las de estar aquí donde
él
dedica tiempo cada semana cada día
realmente a
atacar a quienes él
considera
enemigos o periodistas que no concuerdan
cuando en el gobierno
bueno puntualmente cuál es la situación
que se vive a lo largo y ancho de méxico
porque continúa el peligro para los
periodistas y quién es el encargado de
defenderlos si la impunidad continúa
latente en los crímenes a reporteros al
tiempo que no hay protección suficiente
cuando se denuncian las amenazas
es una muy buena pregunta
y es importante entender el contexto
méxico de manera consistente se
posiciona como uno de los países más
mortíferos más peligrosos para el
ejercicio del periodismo en el mundo
el año pasado se ubicó en en primer
lugar este año queda en segundo lugar
solamente detrás de ucrania en el número
de periodistas asesinados este año y
claramente en ucrania
casi todos los periodistas asesinados
murieron cubriendo la guerra
aqui en mexico
[Música]
morían fueron asesinados ocho
periodistas en los primeros tres meses
del año y eso es importante porque si
seguimos a este camino el 2022 podría
ser el año más letal para los medios en
méxico en toda la historia
bueno en naciones donde los gobiernos
actúan contra los periodistas usted cita
méxico por ejemplo también tenemos el
caso de nicaragua quien puede garantizar
el ejercicio de la profesión
es es muy
importante esa pregunta es uno de los
elementos importantes es que en varios
países de la región como es méxico y
como son otros los propios gobiernos han
creado mecanismos para brindar
protección a periodistas y defensores de
derechos humanos existen mecanismos así
en colombia en honduras en méxico en
brasil
así que una de las cosas importancia es
que los gobiernos tienen que hacer es
fortalecer esos mecanismos en méxico por
ejemplo existe un mecanismo que muchos
periodistas recogen lo reconocen como
algo
importante para su trabajo pero también
han sido hasta 59 periodistas mientras
recibían protección así que no está
alcanzando
o sea no está cubriendo todas las
necesidades pues